man [ __ ] rotten tomatoes fabulous cherry
I dug this film this film was [ __ ]
awesome this to me is the perfect
conclusion of the Neill Blomkamp trilogy
I know no one's called it that yet but
there's district 9 Elysium and now this
I saw some we would Jerry and we walked
out of the theater feeling the exact
same way which was what the [ __ ] is
everyone's problem with this movie and
then we met a fan named Eddie what's up
Eddie I hope that's your name I didn't
walk out saying I see what everyone's
talking about what some of that's good I
looked up feeling like I had a great
movie going experience experiences the
gift from God
so robots are the police force now AI
has officially been invented by Dev
Patel the dude from Slumdog Millionaire
I thought you was like Indian Indian
does it take place in India I don't
remember what Slumdog Millionaire takes
place I'm about to look like a really
good film critic he creates AI the first
program that will allow a machine to
think and feel and I thought I was gonna
become what if the machines rebelled
against the humans type of movie but it
wasn't that like in the first day
halfway through they throw in some South
African gangsters play by D ant wood who
I haven't called Diane wood and then a
lot of people will call you an idiot and
to those people who called me an idiot
you can go [ __ ] yourselves okay I don't
want you coming over any more anyway
they're a South African music group
mingzhou plays a guy named ninja yo
Lundy plays a girl named Yolandi they're
not playing themselves the rioting just
got a little lazy I guess that was like
just kind of taking a different time now
death to tell he has the AI program but
he hasn't yet to install it into a robot
so then he gets kidnapped by the
gangsters they're like hey we need you
to design us a robot that will fight
aura so we can pull off a heist and dan
patel with
no he's in dangerous circumstances now
so he's like I can't do that but I have
AI which can program a robot and you
could teach it like it's a baby on how
to think and feel the way you kind of
want it to think and feel chappies play
by Charlotte Coakley Copley there's a
lot of words I don't know today and it's
done with motion capture like first half
of Act one was okay second half of Act
one was better but the time chappy comes
to life I was just hooked
I had a big smile on my face I was
really just loving this like baby road
hot it was awesome like chappy is just
adorable
kind of like when you want to Wally the
body language and the voice as sharlto
copley vision we're gonna Sharlto for
today the voice that he gave was great
he's also like really funny and you
really care about chappie I like when
chappies in bad situations just because
he is like a baby they have to teach a
robot baby being raised by gangsters how
can you not call that unique that's
[ __ ] weird
you know he is right baby he's a
gangster Bob gangsta but and then when
he becomes 13 gangster buck Mitzvah a
lot of people don't know that I'm
chappie but he's really Jewish you see
this like child learn human behaviors
and he just wants to fit in he just
wants to be loved
yeah actually even thinking about it
right now every moment of chappies
decisions even when it's in the darkest
of times stems from a place of love
beautiful it's beautiful it was a unique
way to tell an AI story the films called
chappie so how is chappie chappie
best part of the whole film and if you
don't walk away saying
chappie likes something everywhere you
go you are paying attention I do the
easy voice when I do chappie
that is not a South African robot then
there's this jealous co-worker of Dev
Patel played by Hugh Jackman anything
you know what they you know they say
when Hugh Jackman jerks off Hugh Jackman
I've seen Hugh Jackman in several films
where he's not playing Wolverine that's
wrecked I have expanded my intellect I
always knew he was a great character
actor a plump introduction of this
character I was like okay I've kind of
seen him do this before just wait a
little bit and you're like wait I've
never seen Hugh Jackman do a role like
this before he's straight up under the
characters main antagonist
he hates the robot police force he hates
the idea of AI and he's ruthless he's
manipulative he's like every like
fifteen-year-old girls
18 year old boyfriend ruthless some
inhibitions it could have easily been a
one-note performance but you get so much
more than that like sister seems you
actually kind of get where this dude's
coming from and same time is like
ruthless violent ways actually makes
sense because he's a soldier or it used
to be a soldier
either way Hugh Jackman's built like a
soldier do you just come across a little
gain interviews yeah yeah that's wrong
with that so he's married and has
children so I'd be very concerned what
are they called gay Hugh Jackman huge
axe man off but who really blew my mind
was ninja and Yolandi ninja was the
leader of this like small family gangers
three of them and he hit the like great
level of humorous behavior to where you
would laugh at him and then you have
this completely other side where he was
a really scary person like he knew when
he could be funny and laughed at but he
also knew when he should be taken
seriously this guy seemed like you'd be
in movies for so long there's like
charisma to his performance there's
confidence he has all the capabilities
of being a movie star except for his
teeth and hair
Sammy can be said of Yolandi she becomes
like the mother to chappie she's like a
tough lady
gangster hmm put him up she's incredibly
sweet you trust her the most
it's another three-dimensional
performance by someone who you don't
normally see in movies all the character
dynamics made sense all of them were
perfectly performed and was shot really
well it wasn't shot like district 9 in
Elysium where most of its handheld
there's always some of that in this
phone the designs were awesome
especially chappie because the whole
time you're looking at CGI but you're
not once thinking it looks like CGI
I also
the music it's like that techno-pop rock
the film is just not the tone and style
that the trailers have been
communicating they tried to murder you
like it's an action film but honestly
that's where my problems with the film
why it's on the third act III didn't
like how they suddenly try turning the
finale battle into an action movie
totally it didn't fit it felt a little
4-6 sort of felt like they did that
because they needed to sell tickets at
the box office but it doesn't really
bother me because there's not a lot of
action in this film because it's not an
action movie there's action scenes in a
sci-fi drama but I will say when the
action was there the reasoning for the
violence being there actually made sense
in the last 10 minutes is a lot to grasp
I was kind of like okay that's a little
convenient end
that's another sci-fi movie but whatever
we can hop on board for now like I think
it's a film about like an extra 20 to 30
minutes it might have been able to set
up the ending but if you guys have seen
you know what I'm talking about
but it is a pretty like honestly in some
ways I felt like this could be a family
film the owners down see it as because
yes there's a lot of swearing and the
violence could just be cut back a little
bit but this is one really violent
moment the only reason I will say don't
let kids watch this movie it's because
of this ten-second moment that is so
shockingly violent I was like whoa I've
been in the theater for like almost two
hours now and there hasn't been anything
in this movie to hint at how violent
this scene was gonna give us that
violent scene sort of made sense let me
get straight to the point here all in
all I gotta say
nice day
all right guys we have just seen my
movie review of chappie hope you had a
good time
listen you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and Facebook
there was actually real rejects last but
at least more get updated ever telling
on my reviews or videos as hell joenie
put on this one of my mind dig to
subscribe that's right dick let me tell
you something out of this little chap
everytime this thinking and feeling
artificial intelligence
once the link up with his woman he's a
lean green pounding machine it's not
killing machines it's parenting mission
as he's a robot